So definitely, the time of day that you took the test could have influenced your
memory. If you're taking the test late at night, you might be really tired, or
maybe your brain just doesn't work in the morning, like one of my friends. He
can't think at all in the morning. That isn't to say that it definitely did
influence your memory, but it could have. The number of palm trees in Hawaii
isn't very plausible to have influenced your memory. Your stress level
definitely could have influenced your memory. If you're really stressed, maybe
you don't remember as well. The price of milk, not so plausible. The five minute
breaks? Absolutely. If you didn't take the five minute breaks, my hunch is that
it might be more difficult to remember which face was from part 1 or part 2. The
Mass of Pluto, not so much. Your age? Definitely. And finally, not paying
attention, definitely could have influenced your memory. And the BBC study
concluded that age and time of day were the two biggest influencers on how well
people performed on this memory test, if you didn't get a chance to see the BBC
test results. So, we're looking at a bunch of different things that could have
influenced your memory, including sleep. We make hypotheses all the time,
everyday.